pulled up and uh anyway that is 613
ranking
we're writing wasn't his rating higher
at the last event i guess maybe he gets
sniped a lot or something
but the game but that's just starting to
split that was okay all right
all right all right all right because at
the rapper we see it's 9 24 and it's
actually higher than it was um
he was like maybe seven 730 750 i
thought so he's actually improved quite
a bit too
okay well i'm gonna i'm gonna flip the
board here to have white on bottom
and uh we've uh we're we're rocking and
rolling game is on we have d4
so queen spawn we had all e4 yesterday
hey caro or no we have one english but
this is our first d4 i think of the
event
yeah i think it's uh it's gonna be
interesting because i feel like xqc
has a lot less experience against pawn
to d4 on move one
and the fact that he's thinking already
on move two is um
is not a good sign i'd say one when
should you start thinking
because i think yeah d4 is i think is
total cheese
yeah so so what i would say is a lot of
newer players who are beginners they
will push the pawn in front of the king
right away it's much more natural the
development of bringing the queen and
bringing the bishop out
um whereas playing pawn to d4 and move
when it tends leads to a slower opening
opening phase of the game and so i what
i would say even at this level is they
should know their first like five to six
move is what i would say and
yeah he's thinking for a while here this
is uh yeah that's that 20 hour he's been
up for 20 hours i feel like
have we not known their studies that
being awake for very long periods of
time is as bad as being drunk
like severely drunk yeah no it's it's
it's worse it's it's worse than many in
many ways um
this is cheating well he played knight
f6 and finton though again i have three
all three of my students are going down
today so i highlighted the next match as
wagga and thor but i also work with
fenton and unfortunately he already
forgot one of my first tips which was
that
when you play this opening they need to
protect with a pawn because if not
they've basically given you your goal of
the big center
when they play the move to knight f6 and
i said the main thing you do is you just
take it
unfortunately he forgot he didn't take
it which would have given him his
better chances of a big pawn center and
now he's played knight c3 so
that's sorry the coach in me taking over
my bad sure sure mad at your students i
get it i get it yeah
um oh now it's turned into a normal
opening like that's the thing
actually it moved the pawn on the second
move we could have had this from the
normal
order yeah um but danny since you did
coach easy with aces i think this is
transposed back into a position that
probably you've shown him
before right yeah so 100 the
transposition happens because as hicaro
said
e6 is the move that should get there but
fenton missed his small chance and now
we're in a mainline queen's game we went
over this i mean he knows
clinton knows get the pieces out you
know you're all right
you see received any coaching from
hikaru um no i reached out to him
multiple times but i i think he was kind
of busy with uh among us and fall guys
so
yeah didn't have a chance how does he
how is he able to squeeze it in when
he's playing among us for 18 hours
i mean he must he must just really love
chess at the end of the day is he
is he playing in the fall guys event
with you guys on the 28th or no
he is in that event yeah yeah he's a
captain is he on your team hey carl you
get to be his captain
no no he he's a captain as well so like
i'm a captain and he's a captain ludwig
i think is a captain also so
we'll all be rivaled that event against
each other although that would be your
dream team
imagine hikaru me you xqc
all right we've got our first awkward
move it's not a bad developing
move normally but oh he's going for
cheese he's going for the cheese danny
you got to show the line on the board so
pawn takes pawn
yeah pawn takes pawn knight takes pawn
and you think white's going to win a
queen
bishop what's the move what's the move
here what's the move right here for
the move right here for black oh my god
okay yeah yeah
so right here in this spot black
obviously gonna grab that bishop
bring him on down to b4
wow you're crushing it
whoa yeah that's what i'm saying so then
obviously that spot
uh scary scary scary cheese on its way
vinton did not take it he did not take
the bait i'm not even sure if he saw the
cheese but he just settles on
eliminating the knight and
now he could win the pawn um it's got
some risk to it but he could go for it
yeah i mean objectively taking this pawn
to be very good i kind of hope he
doesn't grab this punk because he has
not developed any of the pieces next to
his king the bishop the knight and the
rook are on their original squares
yeah um so i kind of hope that he
doesn't grab this pawn
after xcc recaptures with his pawn but
it's
it's gonna i think this is exactly what
xqc wants which is something that
at the start of game is probably not
very good but it's going to be very very
complicated and there almost certainly
will be some blunders
yeah so so what do you know about xqc
then he likes the tactics that's what
you're
implying there he loves these open
positions where he can bring his pieces
out very quickly and attack
okay um why don't we do our first listen
in of the day we've got him streaming
and
we'll uh we'll all take a backseat and
see what see what insights he's
he's given his viewers over there he's
gonna scam me
i have to do this first this is so bad
yeah oh
in the event that this happens i if i
push this and again he goes away let's
see goes away
he he goes away did you say in the event
this is like the most proper i've ever
heard
he doesn't see that the knight is
attacking the queen right now
you know what let's just try it
wait no mike mcqueen's in danger i
didn't look at that okay
wow that could have been game ending
where do i position that lady where do i
position that lady there you go
i think this is fine i get it
i get it that is the question
is pretty cool that's not i'll do that
i i don't like the this is all stacked
up i think this is garbage
at least he can't do this to me anymore
we got that we got this out of the way
and i can start moving do it doing stuff
like this
look at that let's do it he's going so
fast
not that it matters but that's a good
move e4
what is happening
[Music]
do i want that i kind of want that
i don't think he wants that
that exactly he's already way down on
time though he's down more than five
minutes already almost
yes
pawn can just pass you right stress out
the queen well then you lose your knight
that's actually why it's a good move
okay because the pawn protects the
knight so if he moves the pawn you take
and i look at somebody that knows what i
even when i look at somebody who knows
how to play
their pawns look like art they're so big
when i play my pawns look
like they're missing arms and like mr
potato
from um the movie dude like toy story or
whatnot
that's actually not untrue though a car
like when you look at a at a master play
their pawns are like structured there's
a shape
right and he's like yeah yeah he's he's
right about that it does look like art
the pawns where they protect each other
they all make a lot of sense in terms of
the place
what are your pawns look like when you
play lead
you know what i try to just advance all
of them at the same time equally so
they're all next to each other like it's
a small world style
i think that's the safest strat
that's generally that that is generally
a good way to do it because here like
both players with the placement of where
their pawns are on the center part of
the board there's a lot of danger i
think
um for for both sides here because
white's pawns can be attacked easily
black's pawn as well on f5
it's a little bit weak as well are you
stressed about his clock
i've seen yeah i mean this is
this is really dangerous he's got to
move faster he just he's thinking way
too long he hasn't like thought about an
attack either
but this is the best move so yeah that
was a good move
and hicaro made a good point that okay a
big center is nice and you have space
but it's also
a target and that and you got to give
got to give xqc some credit he's been
attacking it we'll see what he does here
let's uh but he's got it he's got to
move he's just got to move
yeah let's check in with vinton we
haven't we haven't seen what the poker
master is up to yet let's do it we just
wanna get ourselves castled
control as much of the center and don't
give up any silly mistakes
when do we go maniac 2000 if we win the
first game and then lose the second one
we kind of left with some egg in our
face but a little mini rave would be
nice
we also have this potentially now but
then this would be hanging so maybe not
we're just going to get castle
i mean the the the bow tie is cute say
that
yeah he looks like the student was
obviously homework and the teacher
forgot
i would like to win with a checkmate but
if he time's over maybe like i said he's
been awake for 20 years possibly he
passes out
were you the student who asked for
homework wow
he knows he knows about the sleep
deprivation
okay this position though is not clear
at all here after black castles the king
this is very very we want to just get
castle before we plan our attack i think
we'll just get castled
we'll just start bringing these pieces
over here okay
um okay look at xqc developing quickly
he's clearly aware of the clock he's
speeding up
okay so how are we gonna talk i don't
know i would rather be black if you want
to remember
i'm kind of tempted to just start
running just looking at finton's stream
and he's like he's definitely the six
consoles type of streamers
these are like polar opposites yeah he's
got the green screen and the overlay
looks like it's a chess.com production
right i don't know if that's a good or a
bad thing but i appreciate it
this is six consoles thing danny
um yeah finton is is super slick and
like i said i always try to describe the
biggest streamer on twitch next he just
rolls out of bed
there you go i mean i'm amazed by what
is a what has occurred by the way
because i i'm not i don't think white is
even better anymore yeah
i agree love it because like ludwig for
example when you get these pawns in the
center
if they're protecting each other they
make a lot of sense but here the pawns
are not secure at all
the pawn on the dark square is under
attack from the knight and the bishop
and the pawn on e4 is also under attack
upon f5 so white could lose the whole
center here
very quickly do you see any major
attacking ideas from either side
um i see obvious sort of ideas to attack
the pieces in the center of the board
for xqc
for sure for easy with aces for fenton i
don't actually see any good ideas to
attack here
try i like the idea though moving the
queen out
yeah the bar went down a lot why
because black can move the king over one
square and then the threat is
okay so for example there's a big
mistake here which would be instead of
moving the king over
uh go back one move black and play
knight takes pawn
because after queen takes white is
attacking but for example you're the
queen is under attack from the bishop
i see on the light square so if black
moves the king over scoots it over one
square first
then the threat of capturing the pawn
with the knight and then attacking the
queen with the
bishop on the light square is a very
strong threat
yep and okay but this probably won't
come up i'm thinking
probably not oh he makes the mistake oh
wow i mean and it's it stinks because on
the one hand it's actually good tactical
recognition he saw the idea of the queen
he understood he could win the pawn
but it's it's hard it's like the the
next the next level is
yeah see the tactical recognition but
you got to visualize it ahead of time
and and now
if easy finds this immediately saw it he
did immediately
drag up the line to a7 oh he did okay
but he didn't see it as like a goated
move it feels like he kind of saw it and
then he's looking at the rest of the
board right now
right so i would say if fenton plays
queen takes pawn he almost certainly is
going to win this game if he does not
take the pawn i think it's very very
likely he's going to lose this game
well it's funny of course too is it is
almost tricky enough that if xqc sees he
can grab the knight with check meaning
he doesn't
he doesn't panic of this and actually
lose the knight like if he sees this
and then frees his king he's not he's
not i mean it's not over over right
there are some outside chances that the
game goes on here
he has had the queen he took the pawn
right he did it
he had it there for like 20 seconds
before he finally pulled the trigger
but if but if xqc sees knight takes f3
with check and then frees the checkmate
it's not it's not red rover yet i mean
he still has some chances
no but it's very hard with two two
minutes on the clock the time is going
down
i i don't i mean i think it's very hard
for him to play knight takes night here
because he's going to be so
he's going to be so um yeah so tunneling
on this queenie checkmate idea here
i will say the pieces that he is looking
at are not a knight yeah
let's listen in let's listen in and see
what's going on
this song's stressful all of a sudden i
know
if i move he just takes that
and i take and then he takes he thought
about all this already
he thought about us already
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay if he moves the bishop he has a
chance
[Music]
now but now he only has one move so
he'll see it right away and now it's
game on again
[Music]
what a weird game yeah yeah because this
has been such a weird game is it think
it's a weird game
well xqc is i still have better gear
unless easy with asus finds one idea
one trick possible to spot
my
[Music]
i think so yeah i call it i love trying
to translate nicaragua i know blood does
that too
yeah yeah yeah that's the sorry wonder
is the parpa tree
[Music]
yeah okay but he didn't find it he gave
a check that's not the best check so xqc
still has a chance
right and the problem with what he's
doing is that execution only has one
move so it's like actually
the move right away that's the problem
with with these moves that
the queen block it was the only move the
king move it's the only move
so xbc doesn't have to actually find a
move he gets two free moves
because it's an only option right
now to be fair if i had this position i
think that i would actually i think
black is much better here
don't move the king please don't move
the king
if he plays b6 he does if he plays b6 he
does
okay okay this is
right so there's actually one big
problem here if you look at this
position what's gonna happen is black
can trade the knight so white's gonna
get those two pawns lined up in a row
next to his king but then also he has
this knight that's kind of wandering
that's that's near the black king and
black can actually trap this knight
by attacking with the king the rook or
the bishop
all three all three options would attack
that knight and the knight is trapped
he's going to lose that night
so this is
and very very very very tricky
yeah i feel like finton's been doing all
the work and then after
everything that happens he car still
goes yeah i like black spot here
yeah but i guess he has he actually he's
doing something right
carl pointed out the unluckiness sort of
is like he gave xqc all only moves like
here
xqc can't not find this move like it you
know
and then he can't not find this move so
he kind of got himself in a weird spot
look at this move c5 oh the knight t5
though
better find a move that you know has
multiple options is what you're saying
yeah because when you only have one
option kind of and it's not even just
one option but
it's a good good only options too like
that makes it very
difficult and i think especially at this
level the more opportunities your
opponent has to make a mistake the
better off it is
whereas when they only have one move
they can't make a mistake they have to
find the one move
feel like you're getting free chest
lessons lead
look i'm already pat i'm like it's like
i'm uh you know i'm like shaq
i'm on tnt now you know what i mean like
i did my tour
i got my championships i was the biggest
at the time
so this was an old season you know i
maybe i could play ball with these
youngins but
you know i'm just taking my victory tour
yeah
um all right okay xuc does find the
check and so the only problem with
moving the c
pawn is he kind of accidentally gave
fenton you know
a saving a saving move but but it's it's
still
it's still tricky the main issue is
clock
yeah oh and that's a really bad move
what
all right what do you want to do let's
go check in with the uh
the kid in school that i didn't cheat
off
but let's go look at him i think we're
just going to not deal with this first
he has a sponsor for emails don't lose
another pond though
that's crazy i don't even understand
that
he found knight g5 this is yeah
now he's gonna win the bishop right and
with that he should win the game
we're going to take this yeah that was
an excellent move
excellent excellent fine by finton going
knight to d5 check first
saving his knight and now i can take the
bishop next move
and it would take some sort of
catastrophic gonna go out here
we're gonna go here yeah
i feel like we should have won this a
little bit easier
probably you should have safety concerns
me a little bit but i don't see what he
can do right now
but uh xqc gets the white pieces next so
a little different for him from pog one
do you wish you had two games per match
in pog one look do you like that change
no no oh yeah i think it's way better i
think only
for the exact reason that no one can uh
make excuses
no john's as they say because you know
if you if you happen to roll
black and then you lose your one game
and you lose the whole match that kind
of sucks
so it just uh gives you the opportunity
i'm sorry
tired deposit you call me lug bud
okay lud i was just seeing a bunch of
lugs in chat
in fact lug is a cool nickname for you
what do you think you're like a lug
that's what my brazilian soccer coach
called me
all right he had a thick accent and i
thought it was his accent and then he
sent me an email and he wrote two lug
and
so he just never knew my name ever
all right let's go see xqc's uh
potential final moments here
kim jiji ken i give my transition
into the loss did you mean did you just
guys i didn't have enough time yo did i
get a deal three
deal right second game that can click
bo2 but you give him a match too
yup i feel like i'm talking to him
i think i had checkmates alone he's
running a game report
don't think he even i think somewhere in
that checkmates
am i crazy i feel like
i don't even know if he had many checks
yeah he had one chance there was one
chance where he could have been better
but it was very
very hard let's go back to that decor
right here after instead of the move c5
what was your thoughts
for what should black do yeah i think
black shirt traded the knights here play
night knight takes knight pawn takes and
then maybe um
i mean just bring the rook over to the
center of the board maybe rookie eight
is a move
um or something like king b7 again very
advanced stuff though i mean that's not
something
i would yeah just so you can open up the
queen lines but again that's very varied
because i would not expect anybody in
this field to find it that's a super
strong idea because if somehow
if you did that with the battery like
suddenly it does turn around so
i think he said he thought he had
checkmate because he knew that the
potential here of
of the double stacked pawns i think he
saw this but
but there was no uh no real concrete
idea
right well he's running a game report i
think both of our players are
are taking an impromptu break he's
analyzing his game and
uh finton has become a fenton stream
he was just there a second ago and look
at this new um
by the way i get credit for that because
i taught him what the
what the word zugswang was and what it
meant in our first lesson
and i was trying to describe it's one
thing that makes chess a unique game is
the fact that you have to move there is
no pass you have to do something and
ziggs wanted his chat loved it
there you go yeah
i mean i have to say i've been a big fan
of uh of easy with ace for quite a while
now fenton's a very charismatic a very
good poker player as well i might add he
seems like
whenever i watch a stream every other
week he uh he wins like 20 grand so the
guys the guy's a beast and i love the
setup he has
um with this uh disco ball even when
he's doing poker and not chess so just
he's a lot of fun to watch he's og too i
feel like we'll compare to a lot of
other streamers
like myself what a cute dog
that's a large animal he's winning the
crowd he's winning the crowd of this dog
you and cutie have a dog yet lud oh we
got a dog yeah yeah
yeah i thought i saw the dog on a stream
one time he's such a whiny [__]
dude
[Laughter]
he's one of those dogs that got too
attached to the owner and then every
time he's not here he's like a omega
[__]
and all i want to do is hang out and i
just put my hand out he's like
all right man whatever
all right well finn playing the carol we
worked on this we worked on the carol so
he's um
one of the things about the lessons with
him is like he's been playing chess for
so long
wait i mean he plays our chess.com like
in the breaks of his poker streams
he's being drinking beer isn't he he
changed the the
the camera so i assumed it was a beer
you don't ching with non-alcoholic
all right everybody knows that any
classy european should
wait it's non-alcoholic no i'm saying
you always you can't you shouldn't ching
with non-alcoholic beverages so i'm
assuming it's a beer here
uh but like it's late where he is right
he's uh ireland
like nine or something yeah yeah it's
it's three it's drinking no actually
he's in malta he's in malta
he's he's a tax cheat like you are
yeah yeah yeah yeah hey it's just it's
just smart business he car at the end of
the day
offshore accounts um i just enjoy the
state of delaware
right now it's beauty
all right we're in it right this is it
yeah this is uh
he has a chance to do another cheese
with knight e5 here maybe
yeah a little nutty but we'll show it
cheese with nuts
it doesn't work if black knows not to
not to take again
but right something like this should be
fine but that's a hard thing to find i i
don't i don't know that'll go for the
cheese
probably just castle
i i don't like this opening choice uh
from
from fenton here i think it's perhaps a
little bit easier for white to play if
he knows what to do with like castles
and bring the rook to the center
but also xcc violated one of the basic
principles he put this bishop in front
of this pawn so this dark square bishop
doesn't have a good way to come into the
game that's actually the reason you
generally want to push the pawns
in front of your king and your queen
first that you have squares for your
bishops to go to your diagonals
but by the way it's an honor to
highlight the ideas that you speak
that's what i'm doing i'm just
highlighting keep hi just keep saying
moved i'll keep highlighting
now now it's your turn now you say
things and i will highlight
yeah this is bad okay
but why right well come on carl come on
because like oh my god
pushing out one of the five there
what i would say about this is that i
think objectively at like a grand master
level it's probably
okay to play like this but there's a big
danger when you're newer to the game of
overextending with your pawns and you're
using your bishops and your knights too
quickly and bring
because it's king again no development
look at this position he's oh
oh oh did he play knight c6 knight tv5
here come here we go
now 85 is nutty oh we gotta listen in i
think he sees it he just sat up in his
chair
he got him out was that even worth it
dude i kind of wanted to feel like
pushing actually i feel like pushing the
pawn now
his thing is annoying me he it's he's
just annoying
i i don't
i hate doing this this makes my thing so
vulnerable i think it's one of the worst
ones ever but maybe i'm completely wrong
what do i know dude look at this
it leaves me so vulnerable
maybe that's what i mean it's always
what's being attacked not what to attack
mm-hmm get my queen out of there is
there like a switch you have to make or
do you just like
dude i mean i i think i think you're
looking at both john rolly but but
i think that's the varying thing is the
more this is like a six-pack
sort of the less respect maybe respect
is the wrong word but the less you fear
i always feel weird
once you stop blundering you have to
worry about what's well yeah because i
think what he's seeing is he's always
worried that
that he's missing something that he's
doing something wrong and we always have
some way to win the game that there's
always something wrong you don't
understand how anxiety-inducing
can i use this visit to my advantage oh
i i mean i
i was there was a time when i had these
issues oh yeah
you walked uphill both ways
but i do want to add one thing so danny
if you go back a couple of moves i
didn't want to point this out because
the one thing that i think is very
important that perhaps xcc is having an
issue with
is he's he's not like sort of
remembering the patterns like
he's played this petrov opening many
many times and the concept is the exact
same here
ludwig you actually probably would
recognize this which is knight takes
pawn
yeah um bishop takes queen and then
knight takes knight and it's a check on
the king and your knight is going to
capture the queen next move
and this is this is exactly what
happened to him in another
situation where it was a queen in front
of a queen on this line and not the rook
um where he lost a very painful game
i mean yeah i've done that against xcc
before and i think he's done it against
me just discovered check and just
looking for like you know that time well
you tried to you tried to actually get
him with that trick in your final game
yeah yeah yeah yeah damn you remember
that
carl remembers everything like you said
crazy you were right to call him out on
the uphill both ways heykara was better
than me when he was eight
so yeah that's why that's why i know he
was lying because he said he could have
divorced
he's hanging when he's nine talking
about how he remembers being
bad what was the worst you were at chess
you were like four
you don't even remember it's when i was
seven but yeah
tough year dude tough year everyone
before seven seven is the most powerful
magical number so it can't be tough
mm-hmm it can't be
like his naruto moment on the swing set
not even gm
crying the sad news
uh by the way in the game though
actually missed a free pawn i don't know
why
you think yeah if you go back two moose
he could have just castles it's
blacksmith
castles oh he could have taken it oh he
had two chances so he had that chance he
also had a second chance wow
i think he's been operating under what
did i do wrong
this entire set and it's been hurting
him because he doesn't look at it is
that the lack of sleep that he's more
worried about his opponent's threats is
it like the paranoia setting in with
like you know like or is it just that he
hasn't played chess in a while
he you know what i would say on that
topic danny and i think ludwig can
probably relate to this a little bit
better than i can
um which is it's just one of those
things like chess is so stressful like
if you're not if you're if you're newer
to the game you like you just use you
assume that you're not smart or you're
doing something wrong it's just like
it's
part of the psychology i think is that
you just you worry you just you're
you're
worrying non-stop about what what's what
what can go wrong
yeah i think just like it's playing in
pogchamp specifically where you're a
competitor and it's not just your people
watching
and if you lose it's not even that bad
you just get a bunch of lull w's in chat
uh it's it's way more stressful when you
make every move because you don't want
to do something
super dumb and you know you know a
decent amount like i think xcc knows a
decent amount about chess
uh and so it's better to try to show it
off and
not make something super stupid happen
yeah well yes it feels like it's just
like to me i feel like it's like one of
those things where it's like this taking
time bomb you're you're trying like you
just feel like one of these wrong moves
and it's just all going to blow up
which of course is what makes us so hard
honestly i think in general most people
play worse
like at these events uh than podcamps
than they do when they're just playing
on just like streaming right now you're
saying
yeah yeah yeah yeah like the same person
they could beat regularly on stream
uh they probably would do worse on in
pog jams
right so i think that's probably a
thingy car right like tournament nerves
and like being able
like if you haven't done a tournament in
a while uh you're a little rusty
on tournament play yeah i would say even
at the top levels there are certain
tournaments that are objectively more
important than other tournaments
and the quality of play for most the
players tends to go down it gets worse
it doesn't get better
so that's definitely true at all levels
we're going to have the question whether
finton remembers on passant or not we
did not go over this in our lesson
you didn't pass all and honestly i'm
watching finton
and he doesn't see it he didn't see it
he doesn't how do you miss all pass all
right that was like the biggest thing in
the first blockchain it was ambassador
and fianchetto baby
yeah one emo for both that was uh
that was a fail right there no one
poisson
well he gets away with it i mean if you
can get over that type
yeah i think it's it's hard to remember
among us that's his among us practice
all right he's impostor right there he
just went for it he's like i'm i'm i'm
crew member the whole way through
and he got away with it didn't get
called out nice yup
well now it's now it's back i mean okay
black is still
got the big center but if xqc just
develops the knight then this move c4
was really good
actually and he's this is totally
unclear again
this is another opportunity i would say
as well for xcc to show that he has
learned and he's progressing because one
of his biggest issues has been the lack
of development and bring
using all the pieces that he has on the
board i still feel like he developed
backwards
mike i feel like he put all his like
pawns up and then brought out
you know yeah i mean it's a little bit
dubious but he's gotten away with it
this is good now he's doing well yeah
i'm sure he's quite for sure
dubious i thought it was i liked that he
didn't take two like he brought the
knight out behind the pawns so he's got
that pre and if he puts a brook on c1 or
even d1 right now because he's
recognizing that maybe this
it might be a little sneaky verb to see
that the rook on d8 is actually
immediately threatening this pawn here
so he's got to recognize that
right but this game also i like even
though he's down on time he's only down
two minutes so he's kept the game is
pretty
pretty level right um but i think
i think he's doing well so far now i
wonder if he's going to try to cheat him
with f3 here maybe
i think i've noticed three that uh that
bad players like me don't do
is you just look through pieces you just
pretend they don't exist sometimes
right right doing it for the chat
f3 would not be advised for the chat but
because
if you don't take it it's bad but but
yeah maybe maybe go for it
yeah i think you should i think you
always go for attacks in these settings
mm-hmm okay if he plays definitely now
this order works too
this order is good too yeah three
i think this game's all about chump
checking all right
let them prove that they know how to
deal with it before you write it off
right i feel like when you're good you
just don't even go for it because
obviously it's not you know
you're gonna set yourself up for success
that they're not gonna fall for
but here's right yeah so like so so what
i would say yeah
so put that like in the chess terms like
you should always go for tactics i think
like tactics these sequences are a
couple moves where your opponents will
uh
have the chance to make a mistake rather
than trying to find normal sort of
positional moves that you just improve
pieces
at some point you should try to play for
these tactical sequences of a couple of
moves where your opponent can make a big
mistake
really bad players will blunder and let
you win and then like okay players you
have to let them beat you
by doing tactics against them and then
good players you just lose
against that's my experience yeah the
better the players are the problem is
like the
these these sort of cheapo tricks these
tactics they don't really work so you
have to like combine everything and use
use
like tactics like then peace placement
it's just yeah it's it's very hard
obviously mm-hmm
just listen is that sorry go ahead danny
no i was saying i'm just listening to
you guys love it let let's let's check
in with xqc looks like he just went for
a different
kind of uh chump check as ludwig would
say see what happens man like a russian
i don't know what that means but that's
out of bounds how do i feel about this
if he sinks that knight in on eight on
b5 that's what a car was saying i moved
like a4
right what about this like
danny every opportunity which is not
prepared for because he has no puns push
like i do
who knows
okay if he plays a4 here he is playing
like a russian
he has to do that well do that
it's the only move
okay here it comes i
push pawn he takes this for free that's
a disaster already no no you guard it
twice no no
it's not looking good to see the knight
retreat because the knight's being
attacked sometimes
like literally at our level we just
don't value it as a piece that can
attack think about because think about
this if i stay here and i'm stubborn and
i push this
he takes that and i'm my queen's in
threat
i move her he pushed my dude
and gets that too well that's nah i'm
not
no that's i'm just gonna go back
oh oh even if i go back he's not the
same option
the music makes me just on the edge of
my seat of weather i don't know
anymore the funniest part about this is
he goes back he makes it into reality
the one thing he's worried about
everybody what's happening
is he going to see it or not yep clock
i guess i want to do is uh
i think he's already written that knight
not protecting his truth
so he'll never go back to see it
that sounds like i think it's a free
piece i don't even know what i'm doing
okay takes
takes okay
he might still do it because he can't
read the line deep enough that he
doesn't know if it's even that bad
and then vincent won't take the pawn
whatever i i was
wow it's crazy he did it and said i i'm
gonna lose the pawn and he's not going
to wait no it's
not that's not even that complicated he
saw it
yeah finally he saw it afterwards
the winning variation here is the
question so i think this is a good
question for you ludwig
oh gosh okay yeah yeah yeah yeah
black in this spot real quick real quick
real quick if i had to guess black
in this spot has to do something right
flip the board for me flip the board for
me
that is not it was that it that's not it
i wouldn't have done that not silly
right
you could have moved the bishop over
with the pawn supporting it and you hit
the queen and the rook if the queen
moves you lose the rook if you move the
queen you lose
or you yeah give me five more seconds
i'm right there
yeah you call that a skewer
so so ludwig when i said that xcc was
playing like a russian the reason i said
is because right now you see this white
knight
it's guarded by this pawn so it's this
is what's called an outpost there's no
piece that can remove the knight from
the square because it's supported by a
pawn
okay if your bishop your can't attack if
the rook and the queen can't attack it
because
the knight just ha it's completely
guarded it's got that russians just do
that that's like a thing right it's a
very positional concept yeah the outpost
i see so he lived in russia
you lived in russia for a summer that i
would not like to forget
a lot of good things happened in that
summer okay okay
all right go off danny
it's a different show that's a different
show but uh
this is like uh what's that story the uh
talking about some
personal machine 2.0 um you know what it
could be the first time we're gonna have
an xqc armageddon right here
because i think excuse me danny ludwig
against xuc was was
armageddon i think well it wasn't
armageddon but it was it was a single
elimination
yeah blood what color would you take in
armageddon pop quiz
so armageddon armageddon is the one
where
you have to win as white but you get
more
time is that right yes uh i would take
white
okay i think makes sense yeah i just
think i i i
the way i play i just look for mates
even if they're cheesy i just look for
them that's pretty much the only thing i
do and i never worry about defense ever
uh that's like fantastic advice that
you're you're full bill murray space gym
you don't play defense
i think i think people don't look for
checkmate enough in these games
like they're always concerned about
position and things like that and the
basic principles which is
good and dandy but they never once think
themselves like oh how am i gonna even
check mate
uh right they just hope they get to an
end game
that is their advantage what's an
endgame right
you know tell you what it is it's an
overrated marvel movie that's what it is
true
true overrated that ending i mean you
can't just do that
all right almost had it by the way if he
hadn't traded the night for the bishop
and he had played this queen check and
queen check idea without trading the
night for the bishop he would have been
much better maybe even winning
but now it's just a draw but black can
just go back with the king and it's uh
it's going to be a repetition i don't oh
you think he goes for that
i i'd be surprised i feel like nobody
has done that in these tournaments and
it's a smart thing to do
but just the idea of going for draws is
not intuitive at all
well i think it's right plus here it's
not really the smart thing i mean he
knows it's a two-game match if he goes
for the draw he actually loses the match
so i think you're right
he has to do something yeah
that's a good move though he's opening
up new lines of shack that would defend
this pawn
i mean you know if queen d1 is played it
doesn't work but you know
what's the added time per move five
seconds
i think we should check in for his final
moments here whether he wins or loses
all right let's do it let's see what
fitting thinks yeah yeah
oh man
i'm gonna be here
i mean if i lose from here i'm quitting
the competition
we'll say i feel like fenton's doing the
thing where your opponent plays fast so
you play fast too
right but he has so much time um
like we can just run and then so if he
checks here and then checks here
take a moment like can he i'm just going
to go here i think
oh no you can't check me the next move
am i being i might be just being
paranoid right now hey you're being if
you just come and attack this like is
that what's going on here
we have loads of time everyone take a
deep breath let's go in the moneymaker
lounge real quick
there it is where is it let's go in the
moneymaker lounge wow quick switching
scene
that's just everyone has to take a
couple of deep breaths you ready you
ready
oh my gosh i love this
chris moneymaker that's not that's not
let's not let him check make me down
here if you're not going to twitch.tv
slash
so much cases and giving him like this
and this came over but i just don't know
that was epic and then i go here he
checks here
i take like i don't i don't see it but
i'm a bit paranoid and danny always
tells me i'm running away from ghosts
that don't exist
i i do tell you let's just take this and
have your friends throughout
all this all right all right that's just
okay he just gave a draw it's fine
that ghost was it doesn't matter he
still wins he has 12 seconds on the
clock
okay so that's actually annoying
oh queen e3 is a nice move we played
we're gonna lose this pawn but it just
doesn't matter
we're gonna go here we're gonna promote
we're all gonna have a good day ten
nine eight seven six five
i don't think that's how seconds work
but he is ahead
oh man
uh oh two queens are better than one
wait no it's oh oh oops
check me
okay let's go let's go all right
tree blunders again don't think we
covered ourselves in glory but hey
we got the job done we can open up
discord i didn't have anything open
that was a great great entertaining look
excuse he was talking about forcing a
draw in his stream at the end there but
i don't know if he
knows that it's not actually best of
three it's best of two
which means a loss in a draw is still a
loss right right exactly it is confusing
because there's like a tie breaker so it
feels like a best of three yeah
but if you're up 1.5 it's still uh i
guess the
the act of drawing is unique to chess
all right well uh the the act of drawing
didn't occur but we do have another
match coming up they've both gone live
they're streaming
don't go anywhere we've got more ludwig
more hikaru and more pog champs when we
come back
and we're back here joined by by both of
our players
xqc and easy with aces guys uh thank you
for joining us first of all
and what's going on um am i supposed to
hear them
sorry what you're we're we're talking to
you right now this is live we're live
xqc we're live
this is nothing we can't hear you so it
doesn't matter
can he not hear us no
can you hear us now he looks great
he's he's adding a lot just with that
smile i don't was supposed to hear them
or not
yeah audio is not set up properly thanks
because i didn't can zoom in
okay
let us know if you can hear us man guys
i can't hear you guys it'll take a
second
yep yeah we actually we had this issue
with hafu yesterday too so
the bottom yes carrot
and then uh what is it so confusing
for like 24 hours or something let's
give them a little break
oh i got it boom yo yo what's up what's
up
yo what up what up thanks man
uh live troubleshooting but uh hey well
speaking of doing things live you played
super well the last couple games have
you been playing games when you're not
streaming on chess.com how much have you
been practicing over the last
month no i'm not the point of myself
i've been um
i'm not gonna lie to you guys i'm a hard
worker but i'm committed
but um it's been a oh but a short uh
shortcomings with that with chess i i
could have done way more
um are you had it all at your prep today
because you stayed up for 21 hours
before playing
hey look yeah i know i know you're from
youtube but
you think you know stuff like i did i'm
streaming i'm a stream warlord
okay yeah i i don't need to prep for my
streaming
about going to sleep before playing a
tournament game you took
one minute on your second move game one
i thought you fell asleep at that point
i'm not gonna lie i was just worried
about look they say sleep exhaustion
yeah
it's we're just wondering about your
yeah you're exhausted i mean are you
tired or are you feeling good
i think that's okay listen can i i don't
i don't want to create drama listen
this way this guy up top is like a chess
caster gm over there
probably i am over there what the heck
is
ludwig doing you're casting it you're
like 900
i beat your ass oh
in a tie breaker like three minute match
if you want to look at the biggest chess
streamer of all time it's not hikaru
it's not you it's me all right that's
why they bring out the big guy
all right the big guns i'm glad that i'm
getting
interviewed by my my co-worker love wig
thanks so much
i did not pray that much i could have
way more i could have been better um but
it's in fun though
so good go ahead no i'm just gonna ask
um
in general how did you feel throughout
these games because even if you haven't
been um
spending a lot of time on chess it seems
like you have improved relative to when
you last played
so did you feel like you were playing
better today than like in the previous
pog champs or do you think that
experience maybe helped you as well
i feel like i had an idea of where my
pieces were going
and had like a flow of things of like my
pieces are moving
i'm moving forward i'm making big
mistakes but i feel like he was thinking
a bit more ahead
and he's like yeah if he does this that
this well i'm gonna do that i made lots
of mistakes dude i made a lot of
mistakes i've already
think yeah we listened in on both you i
think xuc you gave uh
fenton a lot of credit uh and there was
certain times you could have like pushed
an advantage
just like listening to guys like fenton
we'd listen in on him and he would just
he was always like anxious and nervous
and you both were at points but
i was sitting back having a beer i
thought i was nice at one point he moved
his queen up you went hey
you're the game and you were freaking
out about that you had to
move to your couch cam that's my
opponent
yeah yeah what's going on mate yeah oh
son man
wait people
like a poker player i thought it was
like gonna be like like some like 20
year old doing like a hat
which flames on it did
no that's just poker streamer yeah
i thought i was the host
sure sure yeah you did out do us all in
the uh the commentator attire
yeah and the extra streams
uh the extra scenes you had we had the
money maker room and the disco room
fenton you came
you busted out all the stops here today
i was a little bit paranoid when i first
changed the room that it could be
looking like
that i was changing it for you know to
like i don't know cheat or something so
like i quickly changed back and panicked
and i was like you know
it wasn't my move and i was doing it and
stuff so i thought you were seeing i got
scared for a little sec yeah that's what
i see that you know you coach me you
tell me i see problems that aren't there
all right i i don't have any chess
questions for you guys honestly it was a
lot of fun
um your guys your guys's games were fun
and xqc i mean i know
like you said it you were uh maybe maybe
you didn't think you put as much time in
as
you should have but i i agree with you
karo it felt like you you played
you played better than the first event
and i was wondering if the experience
paid off are you feeling at least more
relaxed like you're not nervous about
your matches when you play
well i feel pretty good like i i i was
happy with like um
i i didn't feel like i he
got me like oh no the fork i didn't
think about
oh no the back the back rank he got me i
i
i didn't feel gotten and i feel like if
i if i
if i had crafted my skill i spent like
more time these small details would have
would have mattered like knowing how to
develop how to push my pawns like
knowing what i'm looking for
these are the patterns that are they're
going to come up that i will use later
on or something
uh and singles flare up you know like
two weeks ago
coaching session can we expect a coach
coaching session with uxqc
yeah i'll get back i got lazy and lately
it's been it's been uh
it's been it's been an experience check
your dms it's so sad
cars just reaching out every day like
hey i think i
i think budwig is offering something
nice what's up
i think ludwig was offering to coach is
that what you were doing
no no no no well i look at my profile
my writing goes like up and down i want
my rating to go up
not not okay
look i'm just a commentator this time
i've already done my tour uh
you know i'll take on a few students
maybe in the future i'm a commentator
there
can i have one last thing though that's
really just for xc specifically which is
that
i i don't know if you can bring up the
board danny very quickly but from that
second game there was just
one i already know which one you're
talking about is that there's certain
patterns that repeat themselves like you
see it in one game and it happens in
another so like in this game
i i don't know if you can see the board
right now and zoom but there was this
one position
if you're just holding i'm doing that
yeah yeah you could have played this
knight takes pawn move
and after black captures the queen here
with the bishop
you can take the knight and you're
attacking the king with your rook so
it's a challenge
go get it again yeah and you get to get
his queen on the next move
that's sweaty and this is a pattern that
you had in a couple of
other games as well so it's just
something like when you see this mistake
like
just try and remember this idea with
this with like these checks and and
these discovered attacks for
yeah it's like a pseudo sacrifice
right exactly
i was a little disappointed when you
missed that buddy but i'm hey no i'm
i'm just kidding overall seriously you
played great
yeah sometimes i see a piece i'm like
that's a threat that's a threat that's a
threat
and i i never compute it as like it
couldn't be a tool to get something out
of it you know
right and i felt like you were always
well the way you're talking is always
defensive and you're
like and a lot of the times you were
good and everything was square but you
thought you had done something wrong and
you could have just attacked more
yeah i kind of felt like i haven't been
in that pattern like uh like enough
times
to be comfortable with it that's all
right but i would say in general terms
that is true
is like you you i think this applies
even to like uh fenton for example where
you always assume there's something
wrong you assume you're missing
something because
you're new to the game or you're your
opponent they set some trap that you
don't see but
for the vast majority of the time you're
doing completely fine so i think
confidence is a big big role in just
trying to be
aggressive and attacking especially for
ux you see makes makes more sense
because you're very good at that it's
more
of an instinct thing and you have those
instincts to attack your opponent's
pieces
yep all right guys well thanks for
having me on and
inviting me gg thank you both for
joining us we got we got a match coming
up now between the mountain and wagga
but you guys were awesome and uh we'll
probably catch up with you after your
next match